[Music]
[Applause]
Bruce Feldman covers the sport the
Athletics national college football
writer Fox Sports college football
reporter as well where do you want to
start with this Bruce
I mean I I think it's such a vast
landscape that we're talking about then
where everything is getting overturned
and I think you hit on it where whatever
somebody said two weeks ago who's in a
position of leadership you almost have
to take it with a grain of salt in fact
you do because we've seen this time and
time again it's the money that drives
everything and I know we use the term
conference realignment it's really
conference consolidation and the the
smaller
smaller non-glamorous non-maby Big Brand
programs are getting squeezed now
because there's TV money and it's the TV
influence that's driving a lot of this
and full disclosure like you said I work
for Fox Sports
um but I think it's also it's like a
killer bee killed Vibe right now in
college athletics
but you start to look at what's next
it's Florida State and Clemson is that
what's next
if that even happens
I think those are the that's right now
what everyone's kind of keeping an eye
on Florida State's leadership has really
been vocal about trying to get out of
the the grant of rights that it has with
the ACC which by the way ESPN is heavily
involved in so you wonder is ESPN going
to go bid against itself you know much
like like the the uh Big Ten has heavily
influenced from Fox uh the SEC now has
extremely big influence you know by ESPN
so it's it's a really complicated
dynamic because you have a bunch of
other schools in the ACC you know I
think you'd include Virginia North
Carolina in terms of those States and
what their TV rights could mean from
those States
um I don't think that the fact that
North Carolina is a great basketball has
great basketball history and and some of
these programs that are probably more
basketball schools and football schools
I don't think that that drives the bus
we saw that the last decade from the
conference moving or moving around but I
definitely think the ACC is really the
last
thing at this point before I think we
start to see do some of the uh TV
drivers end up saying hey you should
really sure about this school the
schools that are already in the
conference whether they're in the SEC
whether they're in the Big Ten you have
to wonder if those other other schools
don't really Drive TV Revenue are those
the ones who eventually get squeezed
where this killer be killed Game you
know keeps unfolding well that's what I
was wondering about this that you got
Purdue and Illinois and Maryland and
Rutgers and nobody cares about their
Purdue you know has a pretty good
history there but the other schools do
we really care about their football
programs uh can you say hey we have some
nice parting gifts for you but uh we we
want to move on and bring in somebody
else besides these uh these programs
I mean at some point you know back in
the USC sanctions days USC you know a
lot of money people at u.su are very
frustrated why are we getting the same
rate as Oregon State and Washington
State they don't drive eyeballs we do
and they're along you know we're we're a
long drive and everything and they're
just along for the ride I think if the
leagues make these decisions because
honestly one of the things that
logically you looked at when you saw you
know some of the move momentum for
Washington and Oregon to join the Big
Ten late last week and I could I was
like oh I could totally see why this
makes a lot of sense especially if it
works into a Friday night TV package
that's tied into it but if you're those
other Schools Indiana
um you know you rattled off a bunch of
them Purdue Illinois Northwestern
um you just got further away from the
top by adding you know Phil Knight's
program and Washington I mean they both
have played in the playoff not that long
ago one played for the national title
one you know one has been one has won a
national title you know in the 90s so I
think that is a question that they have
to be asking themselves because
obviously they went along for what they
think is in the best interest of the Big
Ten I'm not ultimately sure if it's in
the best interest of their own schools
but right now what choice do they have
if you're sitting there looking at what
happened to to Washington State and
Oregon State and Stanford and Cal
I'm talking to Bruce Feldman he works
for the athletic national college
football writer and also is a sideline
reporter for Fox Sports their college
football package how could the Pac-12
have prevented this
ugh I think they had one commissioner
who seemed like he never in Larry Scott
who kind of lost track of keeping the
main thing the main thing and was so
excited to like Chase Innovation at the
at the expense of reality and then they
went with another outside the box higher
in George cleavkov who just really kept
on you know I hate to use this analogy
but it's the one that kind of came to
mind as I watched this where it's like
there's an old Seinfeld episode where
George Costanza seems to Bluff his
future in-laws all the way out to The
Hamptons for something that doesn't
exist that's kind of how this felt for
for the Pac-12 where it's like hey you
know I I saw this stuff late last week
people were saying on on Friday morning
Pac-12 schools are cautiously optimistic
quote unquote that this is going to work
out they'd been cautiously cautiously
optimistic for months and almost
everybody else was like hey this thing
is falling apart right in front of us do
you really buy it and they did and I
just think you know it's that expression
he just did not read the room right they
went down this road you know with with
this apple distribution deal that I
think it concerned especially Oregon to
look at and go you know what a couple
years from now we can still have a path
to the playoff we stay in the in the in
the Pac-12 because of the way things are
set up but eventually people will not be
able to see our games and if recruits
can't see you and their families can't
see you you really can't keep keep
recruiting those kinds same caliber of
kids they're going to go someplace else
and the money Gap is going to widen
there was no guarantees into the deal
you know we we reported a lot on this
over the weekend with the athletic about
just what the money was and I think
that whole thing again I just think they
really did not evaluate the the TV media
landscape at least the way Brett Your
Mark who's also a new relatively new
commissioner did for the for the Big 12
he was very aggressive and I think he
had a better feel for the for what was
going on around him in terms of the
media landscape whereas the Pac-12 once
again seemed to be really asleep at the
wheel yeah I don't know how they could
have been cautiously optimistic on
Friday morning when I was told Thursday
night that Washington and Oregon are out
that that that that they weren't even
showing up for that you know conference
call or whatever it was they were done
and that you know then the Pac-12 they
were cautiously optimistic and I go I
don't know what you're optimistic about
because now you're you know you're
losing two of your Marquee schools there
what do you do with these other four
schools now
that's a great question because I don't
know if they do some kind of partnership
in some way with the Mountain West
schools I mean San Diego State there was
a dance with San Diego State that's gone
on for months obviously that's Southern
California they have a new football
stadium really good basketball program
as you know I mean that's into the
Southern California Market it's it
that's a legit program I don't know if
they grab SMU which is kind of floating
I don't know how SMU fits in
geographically but it's a good football
program obviously in Big Market big
media market then you look at like UNLV
we see UNLV you know the Pac-12 has had
a relationship with them moving their
moving both their media day and their
basketball tournament to Vegas I don't
know if they try to get Boise State try
to get
um Colorado State I'm not sure what's in
it for the Mountain West schools to go
hey we like our leadership there now
we're going to go over here where things
seem to be falling apart you know if I
was the force remaining schools who kind
of been left holding the bag I think
they have to look at and go you know
what maybe we look at the Mountain West
they have survived some of this where
the reality is I think right now as it's
a hard reality but I think both Oregon
State who by the way just won 10 games
and that's a legit football program and
Washington state which has had a lot of
success in the last decade I don't know
if if they say you know what we're more
like Boise State we're more like
Colorado State those other guys left us
behind we're gonna go ride with them I
don't know exactly how this plays out
for Cal and Stanford they've had all
sorts of issues internally and and and
from a resource standpoint and maybe Cal
maybe Stanford looks at it goes you know
we're we are an elite athletic program
in all these other sports we're in
championships and produce Olympians
maybe football is is something we have
to reevaluate because it's just not as
viable the way this landscape is shaping
up yeah Stanford football has not been
good and nobody's showing up for that uh
I'll leave you with this I have no
information on this I just speculated on
this you're Lincoln Riley
you're getting ready to go to the Big
Ten you got one more year you got Caleb
Williams could you see a scenario where
Lincoln Riley Goes Pro
if you know I'll give you a scenario one
of my uh buddies Brady Quinn who you
know I think we had this conversation
offline once if the Washington football
team and commanders are awful this year
and they end up with the first pick
Caleb Williams is from there
um he is a he would be a huge huge get I
think he would have been the first pick
in the draft this year if he could have
come out I don't you know again I don't
know if Lincoln wants I think he knows
the NFL will always be there for him I
don't think the idea of taking USC to
the Big Ten is daunting it all to him
because I think he knows I mean we're
gonna see what happens but I thought it
was daunting better when he was at
Oklahoma wasn't there a little bit of
pushback of joining the SEC uh when he
was head coach at Oklahoma I mean that's
been that's been speculated a lot and I
think a lot of people who are you know
especially on the Oklahoma side are not
thrilled with him that he bolted I don't
know if that's you know how real that
was okay I I do think though if you know
somebody said to him hey you can coach
Caleb in the NFL
I I think that would probably be
something he would certainly have to
think about but again I don't know if
he's ready to jump out of USC after just
two years either I mean he moved his
family all the way across country young
kids I don't know if he's definitely
going to make that move but again if if
you start seeing the Washington team end
up going like you know oh and 11. I I
could definitely see them looking at it
going you know what we could get Caleb
we get Caleb's you know play caller and
a guy who knows him better than anybody
we can really sell that as a as a new
future
um you know maybe it's like a Jimmy
Johnson Dallas deal where it's like
we're gonna offer him something he can't
refuse but again that's just uh that's
just a lot of speculation at this point
and that's all it is it was just me
musing out loud I don't don't want
anything attached to this other than I'm
thinking out loud uh Bruce great to talk
to you great work this weekend thanks
for joining us great seeing you Dan
thank you Bruce Feldman the athletic
national college football writer Fox
Sports college football reporter